I used to only sleep five or six hours
okay then I started sleeping on this
eight sleep mattress and now I sleep
like eight nine hours how much do you
sleep firstly I want one of these
mattresses how how much do I sleep I
think I sleep like maybe six seven hours
a day I'm not a big sleeper I'm
definitely not a big sleeper well you
know when you're a child and you don't
go to bed until you're really tired but
when you're an adult you go to bed
because you know you have to do things
the next day I try and avoid the latter
I try and go to bed when I'm genuinely
tired I don't think all tomorrow I have
a busy day better go to bed loads of
adults go to bed when they're not tired
it's just a certain time I don't give
myself a bedtime even if I have to be up
again at 6 a.m the next morning if I'm
not tired at 3am I'll just stay up
what's the worst case that happens
tomorrow I live in life tired who cares
then I get a good night's sleep the day
after that so my my relationship with
sleep is very good because I don't sleep
until I'm actually exhausted